all right what's more likely week five
edition let's get right to it chris the
three-in-one cults visit the
three-in-one browns what's more likely
the colts hold the browns to under 20
points or the browns score 30 or more
which of course leaves a 10-point gap in
the middle that we're not allowed to uh
to to mention well under 20 or more than
30.
i mean i will be just in shock if they
let up over 30 points i'm going under
20. the colts defense has they're the
best defense in football they are i
thought it was the pittsburgh steelers
but after the last three weeks what i've
watched on film and everything like that
like i'm and i know it's not great
offenses but damn the colts are special
on that side of the ball deforest
buckner is killing it mike i watch the
colts and i think a lot of i go this
looks like the 49ers of last year just
flying around the field dominating the
line of scrimmage never miss a tackle
creating chaos um
they're they're pretty special in the
way they look at least through this
first quarter of the season
they're allowing 14 points per game that
is the best defense from a scoring
standpoint in the nfl but cleveland has
three straight games
of 30 or more points for the first time
since 1968 which of course
was something that the ravens did not
the browns i mention that because i know
that when i do it makes ravens fans
upset and brown's fans upset but it's
factual i don't care if facts upset
people 1968 wasn't even the browns these
browns it was different browns it was
still the browns it was still rounds
browns have never done it no the browns
became the ravens and then the the
current browns are an expansion team but
we can have that debate another day all
right giants at the cowboys what's more
likely the giant score three touchdowns
on the cowboys or that
that poorest dallas defense somehow
holds daniel jones and company to no
touchdowns at all well that would be the
shocker of the weekend if cowboys could
hold anybody to no touchdowns i mean so
there's no way i'm picking that oh well
all right i'm still gonna go giant score
three tds if you make me choose one of
the other i mean the giants are
offensively challenged there's no doubt
about it i mean they can't run the ball
can't protect daniel jones can't create
explosive plays but that cowboys defense
is bad and we've talked about it earlier
this week i don't know if it's going to
necessarily be able to be fixed with the
scheme they're trying to run and the
players they got so if you're i'm going
three tds if i got to pick one
yeah i agree with you as well all right
viking seahawks sunday night football on
nbc and this is a narrower gap between
your options what's more likely kirk
cousins throws for 300 or more yards on
the seattle defense or
the seahawks hold him to under 250. i'll
go with the 300 plus yards i am the
seahawks are not going to let you run on
them they're not going to let dalvin
cook so they're going to have eight guys
at the line of scrimmage it's what they
do every week and but then he can't
throw but that's the thing if they can't
ride they can't throw but the seahawks
are different where they can't cover at
all and
uh i think they've opened it up enough
there in minnesota to where they'll
still be able to take advantage of that
defense which is not great and i don't
know if that pass rush is good enough to
get the cousins either if you make me
choose either i'm going to go 300-plus
yards right now
all right uh i agree with you you do
okay reluctant let you ever i have a
feeling it's going to be a shootout
mike zimmer the coach of the vikings has
never beaten seattle and it's probably
gonna be something like 41 to 38
seattle's gonna find a way to win but
the vikings aren't as bad as they were
early in the season all right last one
bills at titans what's more likely they
play the game or they don't
all right well assuming they play the
game
what's more likely josh allen leads a
late fourth quarter scoring drive or
ryan tannehill who leads a late fourth
quarter both of the
clutches qb's we got in the game right
now i mean yeah they really are but i'm
gonna go with my boy blue i mean because
my boy blue just hasn't blinked at any
point during this year so i'll go with
josh allen
yeah i i just
i hope they they play yeah right because
if they don't play
the game there's no place else they can
put it other than in week
18 and i don't think the league wants to
cross that bridge until it absolutely
positively has to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports